Isabelle Huppert Isabelle Huppert that's
that can't be right Greta was directed
by the oscar-winning filmmaker behind
The Crying Game Neil Jordan and stars
Chloe grace Moretz and Isabel Lou Peele
so a very naive young woman played by
Moretz is on the subway one day and
notices a purse and in this purse is an
ID trying to be a good person she
returns this purse - Greta at her
personal house and a friendship develops
that eventually becomes very toxic and
Greta reveals herself to be a lot more
than a sweet lady who's really good at
playing the piano this film was okay
Chloe grace Moretz is really good in the
film she has a lot to do with her
character because she has to go through
a lot of different emotions sometimes
very rapidly in scenes and there's some
physical stuff too that is very
demanding of an actress and I think she
really pulled it off and gave a good
sympathetic performance she was
believable as this naive person who
wasn't used to Manhattan and and you
know living in the city which is really
important to this story working because
she makes choices where anyone who's
ever lived in a big city before is gonna
look at her and be like what the hell
are you doing this is just so many red
flags right now and that can be a little
annoying which is a little more so on
the script which we'll talk about in a
minute but without a doubt the star of
this film is the title character Greta
played by Isabel coupie oh I guess is
how you say her name and I'm trying to
do my best with that but I've seen her
in quite a bit of films mostly French
movies the piano teacher I just talked
about that on the sardonic ass but with
this film you can really tell that this
movie would not even be close to as good
as it is without these two lead
actresses Michael Monroe is also in the
film and she's fine she doesn't have a
very demanding role at all she kind of
has to play the streetwise friend that
is a roommate of Chloe grace Moretz and
she's constantly like hey what are you
doing
this is obviously a bad decision she
sort of like the audience character you
know like she speaks what we're saying
and her role is fine she's okay in the
movie it's just that the script itself
is filled with so many cliches and so
many familiar scenes and you can see
where it's going a mile away it's the
kind of film that was made a lot in the
90s there were tons of movies like this
where there was just this crazy person
who followed people everywhere or he
started out okay or she started out fine
and then eventually they just went nuts
Pacific Heights with Michael Keaton is a
good example there's a film called
deceived with Goldie Hawn and Jon heard
there's a lot of movies that were like
this in the 90s where it was just
completely reliant on certain things
happening or certain things and not
happening Greta displays so many warning
signs early on where just about anybody
would be like I need to get that fuck
out right now cuz this is some bad shit
it's gonna happen I know it and so we're
constantly waiting for our protagonist
to see these obvious signs and she
doesn't and becomes frustrating and yes
her character is very naive it's set up
early on that she's new to Manhattan and
she's new to this type of lifestyle and
she's very trusting when that doesn't
always work out and so you can kind of
give it a pass after a while but then
you know without getting into any
spoilers there comes points in the movie
where some physicality would be a great
thing and she just doesn't do it and I
just have I just have a really hard time
believing that a young woman who is
athletic and able to take care of
herself like chloë grace moretz his
character would not be able to take on
an older lady it just seems very it just
doesn't make sense
goddamn it still there are some high
points to the film there's a great
buildup there's some tension that's
brewing for a while where you start to
wonder when it's about to explode and
when it does it becomes one of those
movies where if you have a hard time
with any awkward public embarrassing
scenes or cringe scenes like that it's
gonna be hard for you to watch there's a
lot of those moments but building up to
that it was pretty effective and a lot
of that is due to have some really good
cinematography the movie is super sleek
looking really well shot
and two actresses who are giving great
performances although the movie is
definitely aiming for a ham eNOS there's
a camp factor here and if it's trying
for that they succeeded still this is a
really well directed film with some good
acting some good suspense but it builds
to a finale that just asks us to take a
lot of things for granted and accept a
lot of things at face value
where I think there are so many
different ways that this character could
get out of the situation she ends up in
and it's just the movie really doesn't
want her to because if she gets out of
it then the movie will end I'm gonna
give Greta a C+ in my opinion without
these two actresses in this movie this
would be almost a straight to VOD script
it's strange to me that they got
involved with it it could be because of
Neil Jordan's oscar-winning background
perhaps it's just that it feels like
there wasn't enough on the page to
really warrant this incredible talent in
the film nevertheless check it out if
you're in the mood for an okay decent
stalker movie you might enjoy it
thank you guys so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]